salut à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport allez c'est parti pour 26 minutes
de direct comme tous les lundis on passe
au sommaire de cette
édition rencontre avec Sophie d'udemont
la nouvelle championne du monde de tir à
l'arc qui est venu décocher quelques
flèches ce weekend lors du concours
organisé par la compagnie d' dlancour
soire de fête au Palais des Sports les
féminines d'lencour ont pu célébrer
cette semaine leur titre de championne
de France de probé lors de la dernière
journée de championnat face à mulouse il
est la nouvelle pépite de l'Étoile
Sportive de trappe à 15 ans Nassim Rafa
vient de signer un contrat avec le club
professionnel de l'aval pour intégrer le
centre de formation évidemment comme
d'habitude tous les résultats du weekend
mais tout d'abord on ouvre notre page
spéciale golf ou plutôt urban golf
ce weekend vous allez pouvoir découvrir
le golf et cette fois-ci en dehors des
Green et des ferway grâce à l'opération
urban golf mise en place par la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 50 ans
enine et la directrice des Sports est
présente sur le plateau du 78 sport an
Kio bonsoir merci d'être là alors tout
d'abord première question on a on a vu
un peu déjà ce que ça avait donné hein
les années précéd
cette opération en gros on va pouvoir
jouer au golf à tous les coins de rue
dans 50 ansin c'est un petit peu ça
l'idée ce weekend exactement c'est un
petit peu ça l'idée l'idée est de faire
venir le golf aux gens l'idée n'étant
pas cette fois-ci qu'ils aillent au golf
pour découvrir l'activité avec diverses
activités ludiques pour permettre de
découvrir la discipline activité adapté
à la fois aux adultes à la fois aux
enfants à la fois également à ceux qui
ont un petit peu d'expérience déjà dans
le golf et à ceux qui veulent tout
simplement découvrir débuter alors ce ce
weekend weend samedi et dimanche entre
13h et 20h vous allez pouvoir vous
essayer au street golf il va y avoir des
ateliers comme vous le disiez pour les
enfants les années précédentes il y en
avait un petit peu moins cette fois-ci
un atelier spécial 6 12 ans le but c'est
quoi c'est d'essayer d'initier par le
street golf pour emmener ensuite les
gens sur les fairway puis pratiquer un
peu plus le golf traditionnel exactement
l'idée c'est de leur faire découvrir le
golf dans un contexte un petit peu
original qu'il n'ont pas forcément
l'habitude de voir en tout cas
d'appréhender de lever également
certaines idées un peu préconçues sur
les discipline en leur proposant donc
des activités ludiques alors
spécifiquement pour les 6 12 ans quelque
chose de oui de très ludique et alors
par rapport justement à ces préjugés don
dont vous parlez c'est vrai que le golf
est une discipline qui jouit encore
d'une mauvaise image entre guillemets en
tout cas image de sport élitiste c'est
un petit peu le problème encore avec
avec ce sport c'est ça exactement l'idée
est de pouvoir profiter de l'élan de
l'accueil de la rider Cup qui se
déroulera sur le Golf National en
septembre 2018 pour faire tomber un un
petit peu ses préjugés montrer aux gens
que le golf reste accessible comparer
bien sûr à d'autres disciplines
sportives qui peuvent être également un
petit peu onéreuses euh mais c'est pas
forcément le cas on peut pratiquer le
golf de manière libre je dirais pas
jusqu'à dire comme le jogging mais on
peut quand même accéder au golf à peu
près n'importe quand pour aller taper la
balle en dehors de faire des parcours
bien sûr et en dehors également de
l'enseignement qui peut être dispensé
par par les différents professionnels
mais l'activité peut rester accessible
et c'est ce qu'on souhaite démontrer
justement en pouvoir en pouvant bah
faire quelques swings un petit peu un
petit peu partout dans Saint-Quentin et
justement parce que par rapport à ce
street golf et ce concept street golf
rassurez-nous ce n'est pas dangereux de
de jouer en ville non c'est pas du tout
dangereux à partir du moment où on a les
outils adaptés on ne joue pas en ville
avec une balles de golf comme celle
qu'on utilise sur un parcours ce sont
des balles adaptées des bird ball
notamment qui sont des balles creuses
mais moins lourdes et qui vont beaucoup
moins loin forcément ça limite les
risques et par rapport à cette rider Cup
vous en dis un mot hein on sait très
bien que la rider Cup 2018 sera disputée
sur le Golf National de de Guill encour
euh c'est vraiment l'objectif c'est
l'objectif rider Cup cette opération
essayer d'amener le plus en plus
possible vers cette rider Cup les
squantinois et puis un peu plus à
l'extérieur peut-être alors c'est une
des opérations que la communauté
d'agglomération pardon a mis en place
c'est une des opérations à destination
du grand public effectivement avec une
autre opération que nous réitérerons
pour la troisème fois cette année en
septembre qui est la nuit du golf là
aussi l'idée est de faire découvrir la
discipline de manière un petit peu
originale voire décalée en pratiquant de
nuit mais au-delà de ça nous avons
d'autres projets qui ont été mis en
place dans les plus anciens dès 2008
avec la Fédération Française de Golf
pour faire découvrir l'activité
notamment au public scolaire en école
primaire permettre aux enseignants
également à terme par le biais de
formation de pouvoir enseigner
l'activité aux enfants de leur classe
avec des ballettes pédagogiques
exctement et par le biais des journées
de sensibilisation que nous mettons en
place depuis l'année dernière dans les
différents différentes communes euh et
d'autres projets à caractère plus social
avec l'école de la deuxième chance par
exemple avec le club face et également
l'opération crocoolf qui a donc été
initiée en 2008 avec la Fédération
Française de Golf le Secours populaire
et la Fondation Lacoste que de de beaux
projets évidemment 2018 c'est déjà
demain en terme d'organisation où en
êtes-vous justement de de cette
préparation d'un événement qui est
planétaire il faut le dire à la Raider
Cup c'est c'est donc cette finale on
peut le dire un petit peu entre les
joueurs européens et les joueurs
américains qui se déroulent sur
plusieurs jours et il y a évidemment
l'élite du golf mondial c'est ça l'idée
de confronter les deux continents
européens et américains donc tous les 2
ans et tous les 4 ans en Europe ou en
alternance aux États-Unis sur le projet
d'accueil de la rider Cup nous
travaillons en très étroite relation
pardon avec la Fédération Française de
Golf qui elle-même est en lien avec
l'Européan tour la Fédération Européenne
euh nous avons abordé différents sujets
le principal étant l'accès au Golf
National puisque l'on attend environ
50000 spectateurs par jour ce qui est
très important il y a tout un dispositif
d'accessibilité qui est à mettre en
place donc à réfléchir en amont c'est ce
que nous faisons actuellement très bien
donc on peutura découvrir l'Urban golf
ce weekend anal Kio donc samedi et
dimanche entre 13h et 20h un petit peu
partour sur Saint-Quentin il y aura au
centre commercial de Montini au qu
François truffo ou encore au parc des
sources de la Bièvre merci beaucoup
d'être passé sur le PL bateau du 78
sport le Secours populaire des Yvelines
organise des bapthèms de BMX pour les
enfants au Vélodrome national de 50 ans
en yeline l'occasion d'ouvrir à tous un
équipement prestigieux et de qualité
sensation garantie pour les jeunes
cyclistes Olivier Manis Scalco et
Patrick Jacques de
dixm des enfants sur la piste des grands
depuis le 7 mai le Secours populaire des
Yvelines organise des baptêmes gratuits
pour des enfants défavorisés de 6 ans et
plus sur le terrain BM mix du Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
donc on prend bien milieu de virage tout
en pédalant on arrive assez vite devant
la première bosse et puis après on
laisse aller à PL des séances
d'initiation encadrées par un
professionnel qui permettent aux plus
jeunes de découvrir les sensations d'une
structure d'habitude réservé aux
athlètes de haut niveau les sauts ouais
surtout quand on sautait ça faisait des
sensations ouais qu'est-ce que ça fait
comme sensation bah ça fait des choses
en ventre ça fait des sensations que tu
VO
c'est bien et il y a plus de saut c'est
plus réaliste euh au début ils arrivent
ils pensent même pas qu'ils sont capable
de pouvoir de pouvoir descendre la bute
de départ ils se mettent un petit
objectif et il passent une étape même si
certains enfants possèdent déjà un vélo
les qualités d'une telle piste de BMX
leur resteraient en temps normal
inaccessible le Secours populaire permet
donc à ces jeunes cyclistes d'abandonner
pour une bonne heure le bitum et les
trottoirs de leur quartier
financièrement ils ont pas la
possibilité de d'avoir forcément un vélo
chez eux et puis le BMX c'est un sport
ass MOS encore que le véloipe VTT du
coup c'est vra que pouvoir le faire en
plus sur une piste C l'équipe de France
qui est d'autant plus intéressant les
GAMS sé les gamins sont ven il vou
plustir du coup ça bien TR autres
bapthèmes BMX sont encore prévus le 25
juin et les 16 et 23 juillet
ce samedi 14 juin serura donné de de
très bonne heure le départ du 9e tour
sudiveline où sont attendus près de 200
coureurs un pleuton qui traversera 12
communes notamment pendant pendant ces
quatre étapes et l'organisateur de ce
cette course à étape est présent sur le
plateau du 78 sport Olivier Bourdin
bonsoir à vous vous êtes aussi un
président de l'US poignie rambouiller
cycliste merci d'être là tout d'abord
première question donc c'est un une
étape une course à étape pardon sur sur
de jours comment ça va se dérouler il va
avoir des contrôles à montre j'imagine
un prologue en première étape un
prologue en première étape le samedi
matin petit prologue de 4 km qui sera
suivi le samedi après-midi par un
circuit de côte dans la région de
saint-lian d'veline et montfortlamorie
le dimanche matin un contre à la monte
par équipe qui est magnifique à voir de
visu sur le bord de la route qui se
situera qui se déroulera entre
rambouiller et gazerand et nous finirons
par un circuit aussi avec de belles
côtes puisqu'on passera par la Vall
ureuse les vaaues cerné pour arriver à
vieille église ou une boucle de 17 km
qui qui conclura ce ce 9e tour sud
Yveline quatre étapes donc vous le
disiez c'est le l'occasion de mettre à
l'honneur le le cyclisme amateur cette
course à étape tout à fait le cyclisme
amateur de niveau régional puisque on
pense souvent aux grands aux élites mais
c'est vrai que Ben le celui qui fait son
son hobby son sport ben on n pense pas
souvent donc là ça va être leur petit
tour à eux oui justement c'est c'est
très rare c'est de plus en plus rare
même c'est courses étape au niveau
amateur c'est un peu le leur tour de
France à eux à ces 200 coureurs qui sont
attendus ce weekend c'est leur tour de
France à eux puisquil y a des maillots
donc des étapes des
classements donc pour eux oui c'est
vraiment leur petit tour de France dans
la région puis on a la chance d'avoir un
beau beau profil une belle région donc
ça s'y prête oui justement au niveau du
parcours est-ce que ça sera plutôt
roulant il y aura un petit peu de de de
côte comment ça va se passer bah on a la
chance d'avoir le tout on a des belles
routes donc très roulant pour les contrô
la monte des côtes puisque du côté de
gambzil nous avons une belle côte Vallé
de chevvreuse avec les vaau de cerné
aussi de belle côte et aussi un peu de
plaine en sortant de rambouillé
direction immencé donc là aussi ben on a
tous les tous les thèmes du du vrai
cycliste c'est un une course à étape qui
est ouverte plus au barouer au puncher
comment vous vous la qualifiez il y a
des étapes pour tout le monde parce que
bon un bon sprinterur il peut
s'accrocher et puis arriver au sprint
bon après comme on dit c'est les cour
qui font la course il y a de quoi faire
des échapper maintenant il y a des des
bons baroueurs peuvent tirer leur bon
épingle dessus du jeu comme je le disais
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que les
courses à étape sont sont peu nombreuses
en Île-deFrance il y en a quelquesunes
elles se compte un peu sur les doigts
d'une seule main c'est de plus en plus
difficile d'organiser ce genre de
compétition déjà d'organiser une course
en une journée déjà c'est difficile
alors quatre l'une derrière l'autre sur
de jours sur un weekend c'est encore de
plus en plus compliqué c'est pour ça
qu'on a beaucoup moins d'épreuves de ce
type et donc oui c'est très difficile
donc tous les ans on a un dossier qui se
qui s'agrandit à niveau autorisation
niveau réglementation ce qui est un peu
normal pour respecter un peu les règles
de sécurité bon voilà mais donc c'est
pour ça la difficulté fait que ben on a
de moins en moins d'organisation de de
ce type en terme de logistique vous
allez avoir combien de de personnes au
niveau de l'organisation pour sécuriser
les routes par exemple ou ce genre de
chos bah sur de jours on mobilise 80
bénévoles sur pour les différentes
tâches de sécurité de course et 10 motos
pour la sécurité des des coureurs pour
l'encadrement les ivines sont de plus en
plus une terre de cyclisme Olivier il y
a évidemment l'implantation du Vélodrome
à Saint-Quentin le le passage régulier
du Tour de France et puis ce ce contrat
renouvelé pour le parinis c'est c'est le
département idéal pour faire du vélo non
bah c'est département idéal comme je
disais tout à l'heure on a un profil on
a des paysages magnifiques à la porte de
Paris donc c'est vrai que c'est l'idéal
pour partir ben de Paris pourer faire le
tour de France et c'est vraiment le
profil idéal est-ce que certains de vos
des coureurs du du pleuton Coch cach
directement votre tour ce ce tour de
pleine et forêt d'Eline sur sur leur
calendrier c'est vraiment une date
importante pour tous les coureurs de
l'îlede-france et peut-être aussi
au-delà je sais qu'il y a des coureurs
de camp qui viennent notamment oui bah
il le coche oui parce que c'est un
objectif pour eux puisque bon quatre
étapes en 2 jours donc faut être prêt
physiquement puis bon bah c'est c'est un
peu le championnat comme on disait c'est
le petit tour donc c'est vraiment les
les costaud qui sont là donc on veut on
veut faire bonne figure et puis oui on
commence à prendre de la bonne
notoriitté puisquon des courotes qui
viennent du nord de C de Lyon donc oui
c'est vraiment coché en début d'année
les coureurs cochent cette épreuve
est-ce que vous rêvez il y avait la
directrice des sports Ann qui était là
tout à l'heure d'une arrivée future à 50
ans vine peut-être pour essayer de
s'expatrier un petit peu à la mode du
Tour de France qui va démarrer cette
année du Royaume-Uni et puis pourquoi
pas une arrivée sur sur le vélodrome on
est ouvert à tout on regarde depuis
c'est le 9e donc on se développe tous
les ans on prend une petite chose en
plus on on essaie d'innover donc ben
pourquoi pas dans les années à venir
arriver au survéodrome ça serait
magnifique pour les coureurs oui en tout
cas en 2014 le départ pour si vous
voulez suivre déjà la première étape le
prologue c'est à partir de 8h30 c'est ça
et donc la remise des prix du classement
général dimanche 15 juin à 17h30
notamment après ces quatre étapes merci
beaucoup Olivier d'être passé sur le C
sport on suivra ça de de près cette
course à étap donc ce tour sud
Eveline ce weekend la compagnie d'arc
dlancour en tir à l'arc évidemment
organisa un concours extérieur sélectif
pour les championnats de France et parmi
les quelques 400 archés présent la
nouvelle championne du monde Sophie
d'udemont était présente sur le pas de
tir pour décocher quelques flèches
claire Cambier pour les
image depuis son titre mondial anime il
y a de mois Sophie d'udemont est
désormais très attendu sur les pas de
tir c'est la fierté du pays elle est
reconnu à l'international elle gagne
tous les concours qu'elle fait première
mondiale enfin exactement surtout qu' a
pas longtemp il était encore classique
là tout de suite première saison en arc
poulé elle a battu tout le monde à 40
ans et pour seulement sa Dee saison en
arcapouli Sophie deudemont a décoché son
premier titre international et a
enchaîné il y a 3 semaine en battant le
record d'Europe du nombre de points
inscrits en extérieur aujourd'hui je me
pose la question qu'est-ce qui manque
encore comme tout sportif à un certain
niveau c'est vrai que voilà moi en
classique j'ai fait du classique avant
je suis Médail olympique ma carrière
sportive commence à être bien remplie et
ça fait plaisir malgré cette excellence
la sociétaire du club de viler Lebelle
n'est pas parvenu à se qualifier pour
les phases finales des dernières étapes
de Coupe du Monde une preuve du niveau
du plateau international actuelle
aujourd'hui on est vraiment sur un tir
de précision surtout en arcapoui qu on
voit les hommes sur des matchs ils font
150 sur 150 à 50 m ils sont départagés à
la plus belle flèche au centre on se dit
mais c'est c'est super impressionnant
membre de l'équipe de France depuis 25
ans Sophie de Demont semble bien décidé
à ne pas ranger ses flèches et tire
désormais après le record du monde du
nombre de
points le jeune homme que vous allez
voir apparaître à l'écran et la nouvelle
pépite de l'Étoile Sportive de trappe à
15 ans Nassim rafaf vient de signer un
contrat avec le le club professionnel de
l'aval pour intégrer le centre de
formation du club mayennais repéré en
septembre dernier Nassim avait été
supervisé à H reprises par le club cette
saison il faut croire que bah ce jeune
milieu de terrain plein d'abnégation et
de créativité bal au pied a tapé dans
l'œil des recruteur un destin
exceptionnel pour celui qui au départ
voulait faire de l'athlétisme et qui est
arrivé sur les terrains à l'âge de 6 ans
cette saison Nassim évoluit également
sous les couleurs de la sélection
ivelinoise et de l'équipe
île-de-fance moi j'avais jamais bougé de
trappe et quand je partis là-bas c'était
grand il y avait plein de
terrain j'ai bienimé c'est le premier
pas plus dur maintenant fa que je
travaille le projet de formation qu'on
lui a proposé c'est un projet où il va
il va être il va devoir s'engager à fond
il va être obligé de travailler plus que
les autres gamins donc il va falloir
qu'il associe donc son travail à l'école
au travail sur le terrain donc au centre
de formation on a pour objectif d'allier
de et de de de chercher l'élite et le
jeune joueur trapiste a déjà pu passer
quelques jours à la Val au centre de
formation pour repérer les lieux en
avril Nassim et le 8e joueur trapiste en
l'espace de 7 ans a intégré un centre de
formation d'un club professionnel
direction donc l'aval au début du mois
d'août pour son tout début de contrat le
chemin ne fait donc que commencer pour
ce jeune footballeur en tennis de table
si la montée en ProA était assurée
depuis 3o journées les féminines des en
cours avait à cœur de conclure la saison
sur une bonne note cette semaine à
domicile devant leur public afin de
recevoir le trophée de championne de
France si cette ultime rencontre de
probé face à mulouse ressemblait à s
méprendre à un match de gala Les
féminine des lancour tenaient à finir
sur une bonne note devant leur public
c'est penelopsol qui ouvre le bal mais
la petite gauchère passe à côté et cède
rapidement le premier point 37
à0
yanaang qui n'a perdu qu'un seul match
cette saison prend rapidement la relève
et s'impose facilement sur le même score
face à Catalina
gatinska si cette saison est historique
pour Enour avec la montée en proie les
joueuses de Franck solniier ont souffert
pour arriver au bout à l'image d'une
anofigant souffrant d'une entorse au
coude depuis un mois mais qui a voulu
tenir son rang pour cette ultime
rencontre elle s'impose dans la douleur
trois manches à une après une deuxième
victoire de Yanan Wang comme un symbole
c'est l'enfant du club penelop qui offre
le point de la victoire aux aan
courtoises le CTT s'impose 4 matchs à un
et peut enfin fêter son titre de
champion de France c'est une belle
histoire j'espère qu'elle qu'elle va
continuer parce que on va partir dans
une nouvelle aventure qui qui sera pas
simple voilà parce que c'est c'est c'est
quand même un autre milieu un autre
niveau et donc bon il y a il y aura
quelques étapes à franchir mais on est
déjà on va on va savourer quand même ces
petits moments là il y en aura pas
beaucoup on en aura pas beaucoup dans
notre de notre carrière sportive c'est
bon la saison est enfin terminée et on a
tout le monde a très bien joué depuis au
début malgré que il y a eu des
difficultés sur sur les autres équipes
mais après on a bien gérer tous les
filles ouais pour la plupart elles
évolueront pour la première fois dans
leur carrière en ProA et elle devrait
pouvoir compter sur le renfort d'une
nouvelle joueuse d'expérience pour se
maintenir dans
l'élite allez on passe à l'essentiel des
résultats du
weekend et ce weekend faisait office de
retrouvaill pour plaisir et Orléan pour
le compte de des 8e de finale allée de
fédéral 3 de rugby et Orléan s'est
imposé pour la 3 3è fois de la saison en
trois confrontations face au PRC 29 à 13
en baseball 8e journée de Division 2
Montini 2e s'est imposé facilement sur
le terrain du 4e voréal dans le Val
d'Oise 11 à 10 le matin et plus
largement l'après-midi 24 à 6 et vous
allez le voir au classement avec cette
11e victoire de la saison les cougar
conforte leur place de dauphin derrière
le leader La Rochelle à deux journées de
la fin de la saison régulière les
joueurs d'Alexandre Couton sont assurés
de jouer des play-offs en fin de saison
le ramur versaillais Thomas Barou fait
encore des prouess et cé une nouvelle
fois illustré ce weekend après sa
médaille de bronze au Championnat
d'Europe il y a 10 jours il a été sacré
champion de France en deux Barret avec
ses coéquipiers Jean Nouri et Henry
Valley Thomas Barou se tourne désormais
vers les Mondiaux d'Amsterdam en août
prochain ce weekend Guill encour a
accueiller un gala assez exceptionnel
d'art martiaux moderne au gymnase de
l'aviation gala organisé par le boxing
art 78 si la compétition de MMA vous le
savez est toujours interdite en France
les combattants peuvent se défier en
pancrass en mettaille ou encore en
grappling les spécialistes français
sétaient donc donné rendez-vous sur le
ring à Guill encour et il n'était pas
venu faire de la figuration pour ce qui
était l'occasion de montrer à un large
public un panel d'art martiaux modne je
m'entraîne toute l'année donc quand on
prévient de moi à l'avance je suis déjà
dans le bain je suis déjà bien
physiquement j'enchaîne les compétitions
dans l'année et donc voilà les deux
derniers mois on va dire que j'ai mis la
gomme à l'entraînement circuit training
beaucoup de sparring beaucoup de
répétitions techniqu et donc voilà on va
dire deux bon mois d'entraînement c'est
vraiment bien des organisations comme ça
qui mlent box taille boxe anglaise
kickboxing grapping donc c'est
intéressant de mélanger un petit peu
toutes ces disciplines pour permettre
aux nouveaux adhérents qui sont un petit
peu réticents qui voient le l'étendu du
sport quoi ça y est ils sont en mer
depuis samedi Christophe papillon et
Clément hot originaire de milmont dans
les ivelines ont pris le départ de la
Great Pacific race 2014 cette course à
la rame sans escale longue de 3900 km
qui rejoint la Californie à Hawaï arrivé
aux États-Unis à la mimai pour finaliser
leur préparation Christophe et Clément
sont les deux plus jeunes participants
de cette édition 2014 et ils espèrent
rallier l'arrivée tenez-vous bien en 50
jours soit 14 de mieux que le record
actuel et après plus d'un jour en mer il
pointe à la 5e place du classement
général allez avant de nous quitter on
passe à l'agenda de votre weekend de
rendez-vous à ne pas rater on en parlait
tout à l'heure l'Urban golf samedi et
dimanche vous pourrez vous essayer au
golf dans les rues de 50 ans en Eveline
practice putting swing le tout au milieu
des immeubles entre 13h et 20h et Paris
Rambouillet lors de la 3e édition du
Paris Rambouillet vous pourrez découvrir
une centaine de véhicules centenaires ce
dimanche 15 juin lors d'un rally
automobile de prestige des mythes
duubitum qui traverseront Versailles la
vallée de Chevreuse pour à rambouiller
DESS 13h30 dimanche c'est la fin de ce
78 sport merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain d'ici là une
excellente soirée sur
TVfil